Speaker 1: Let's go to Louis from New Brunswick.
Louis from New Brunswick. Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today? Louis from New
Brunswick. I see that you've muted yourself.
If you unmute yourself, we'll be able to talk.
Speaker 2: Oh, sorry. That was that was my
mistake. Go. Thanks for having me, David. Great.
Great to be here. Love your show. Pleasure.
About a month ago, about 20 retired intelligence
professionals penned a letter to the Wall Street
Journal stating that, in their opinion, the
Hunter Biden laptop story or all the hallmark
signs of a Russian PSYOP operation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and in fact,
I believe it was 51. What number did you say? 20.
I'm reading that it was 51 former intel officials.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. Yeah, you're right. I was
just guessing based on my, you know, for memory,
but 51 And then then I remember you covered a
story a while ago of this strange origin story
of how Madison called through and got married.
You know, some Russian woman came over to the
U.S. and like a fake fitness competition.
My question to you. My question to you,
Dave, is do you think that Russian intelligence
services are much more ingrained in our society,
that we don't that we, like, accept or consider?
Speaker 1: So I think Russian intelligence is much
more infiltrated in the United States
than the average person is aware of. I
think our intelligence agencies know the
degree to which it's the case. But yeah,
I think that there are all sorts of ways in
which the average American isn't aware. But
it's not just Russia. I think it's important
to mention there's lots of countries whose
intelligence services are very ingrained and
very slick, but Russia is certainly one of them.
Speaker 2: In your opinion, do you think it's
possible that the Donald, the political Donald
Trump that we are aware of? In the current sense
is in fact a product of this sort of infiltration?
Speaker 1: No, I don't have any
evidence for that. I think, you know,
we have to be really careful because next thing
you know, the right wingers will be saying, oh,
you you thought there was going to be video of
Trump and Putin planning stuff. I think Trump
is sort of a useful idiot for a lot of different
movements and people. And it's very clear from
what we know that Russian intelligence took an
interest in Trump decades ago. To some degree,
as they take an interest in many American business
people, it's not unique to Trump. But over time,
they clearly realize Trump is kind of a doofus and
his ego and his narcissism maybe make him a more
interesting ally in some sense. And at the end
of the day, we know Russia had a preference for
Trump over Hillary in 2016. Doesn't mean Trump's
an agent or a spy or anything like that. He's just
kind of a useful idiot. That's the reality.
Speaker 2: Okay. I guess that's
comforting in a sense, to her. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, we don't have to go
more conspiratorial than the facts point to, but
to say there's nothing there. I mean, listen, he
was doing he was being invited to Russia decades
ago. Russia was casually cultivating him the way
they do many. And they had a preference for Trump
over Hillary that we can say with certainty.
Speaker 2: Okay. Got an economic
question for you if you have time. Sure.
So I got into a lively conversation with a couple
of buddies at work, some all over the political
spectrum. And I was I was wondering if you feel
like Social Security is a socialistic program as
opposed to, you know, looking at the spectrum,
the political spectrum, economic spectrum,
as opposed to like a fascistic policy?
Speaker 1: Okay. I was. Here is the issue
with these terms. All right.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: In some very general sense, any time
you collect money for a program through taxation
and then distribute the money in some narrowly
defined way, you can argue it is in a sense,
socialistic. In practice, what we're talking
about here are capitalist economies with social
welfare programs where the vast majority of the
money you make at most incomes you get to keep
some slice of it goes to programs and there is
some redistribution there. There is certainly
there are certainly folks who get more than
they put in and vice versa. That doesn't mean
that it is a socialist country or economy. We
might just be saying there are certain areas
where we want to use the collective
good for the betterment of society,
and it becomes almost semantic when people say,
Is it socialistic? Well, maybe. What do you mean
by that? But these are programs that every social
democracy, which are capitalist countries have,
and it makes what we call it kind of irrelevant.
Speaker 2: Hmm. Interesting. Well, yeah, because I
felt like I feel like a universal, universal human
response of disgust is towards hypocrisy. Does it
matter? Like what religion, What creed? You know,
everybody is usually offended by hypocrisy. Yeah.
So if this person was saying, like, you're
very, very right on the on the spectrum.
And was looking forward to receiving
Social Security. And I was like, Well,
it's funny because that you're so excited
about that because I consider something
like that. And also unemployment insurance.
Speaker 1: Socialistic policies where they yeah,
I don't think they're socialistic. I think they're
just social safety nets that that that are put in
place in capitalist societies. And by the way
I mean you pay into Social Security so it makes
sense that you should get money out and that
in that sense, that's nothing like socialism
by their definition. So these semantic
discussions in my mind really missed the point.
Speaker 2: Louis Interesting. David,
it's been a pleasure talking to you too.
Speaker 1: The pleasure has been all on this
side of the microphone. Louis Thank you.
All right. There it goes, Louis. Thank you
to everyone that called in. That does it
for today. We will take a break and we will take
calls again if I have anything to say about it.